okay hi everybody I'm Nick Gillespie
thanks for coming out two reasons DC
headquarters for our panel discussion
today about libertarian perspectives on
abortion this is obviously an important
issue it's one that's also most in the
news recently from the Gosnell trial in
Philadelphia where a late term abortion
Asst was found guilty of I guess three
counts of murder so this and this is
also something within the libertarian
community that is an interesting
question because I personally know
people who are hardcore libertarians
that are against almost any form of
abortion others who are open to
virtually all forms of it and various
people in between and what we're going
to do today is kind of talk to
representatives of those three broad
viewpoints and kind of have a
conversation first among the three
panelists and then also with the
audience here so let me introduce first
i'm nicholas bay with reason TV and
reason.com
we have Katherine manga Ward the
managing editor of Reason magazine we
have Ron Bailey or longtime science
correspondent and we have Molly
Hemingway who writes for ricochet edits
at ricochet as well as get religion org
and let me just go through a couple of
quick points about abortion and how we
got to a point where it was legal and
what the current status of it is around
the country and then we'll open it up to
the discussion one of the things that's
interesting about abortion it was
legalized at the federal level or by the
federal government through Rev versus
Wade in the early 70s before that 30
states considered had abortion being
illegal under all circumstances
including for the health of the mother
another 20 states allowed for variations
on abortion ranging from things about
considering the health of the mother
whether or not the child was likely to
be born with severe defects birth
defects and things like that other
mental health of the mother was a
consideration in a couple of states but
essentially only two states I believe
that were Washington in New York State
before Roe vs. Wade
actually had effectively abortion on
demand that we have since Roe vs. Wade
Roe versus Wade created a controversial
three trimester kind of set of criteria
by which abortion was either more or
less legal essentially the Supreme Court
and I'm somewhat reducing this but
summarize summarizing it but the Supreme
Court said that basically through the
first trimester a woman could have an
abortion for any reason without any
questions being asked in the second
trimester the state developed some kind
of stake in the in the the disposition
of the fetus or unborn child and in the
third trimester there could be fairly
serious restrictions put on abortion in
1991 there was another Supreme Court
case which essentially changed that into
the moment of viability when a fetus
that the state started having a real
interest in in the outcome of the
pregnancy once the fetus child however
and we'll talk about how we should talk
about this stuff
reach the point of viability where it
could live outside of the mother to give
you some quick updates according to
Gallup which has been looking at
abortion attitudes towards abortion for
many years currently about 52 percent of
Americans believe that abortion should
be legal under some circumstances 26
percent think it should be legal under
all circumstances and 20 percent think
that it should be illegal under all
circumstances and interestingly those
attitudes have varied a little bit but
they're roughly similar to where they
were in 1973 when Roe vs. Wade was
decided currently 48 percent of
Americans consider themselves pro-life
and 45 percent considered themselves
pro-choice their if you go back to 1973
there's been a vast change in 1973 56
percent called themselves pro-choice and
only 32 percent called themselves
pro-life last year there was about
and abortions performed in the country
basically since Roe vs. Wade about 50
million abortions have been performed
and there's interesting range of
estimates of how many abortions took
place before Roe vs. Wade with credible
estimates ranging anywhere from about
200,000 a year to about a million a year
and interestingly there's pretty good
documentation that during the 1930s
there were about 300 or 400 thousand
abortions a year so abortion was not
even if it was illegal it was not
unknown and we'll talk about apart from
questions of the legality of it in the
morality of it how do you deal with
something that's going to happen
regardless of legal considerations and I
guess well the well the one last thing
that I'll tee up as a starting point CNN
and USA Today have been tracking
attitudes towards abortion the legality
of abortion by trimester and they found
most recently that 64 percent of
American adults think that abortion on
demand essentially unrestricted abortion
64 percent believe it shouldn't take you
know it can take place in the first
trimester by the third trimester only
13% think that abortion should be
allowed so you know there's an
interesting kind of slight as pregnancy
gets closer to birth people's
willingness to say abortion should be an
absolute right it starts to dissipate so
we'll start with that and we're going to
run through we're gonna have a quick
conversation and hopefully an in-depth
one but I'll push things along but the
first thing that I want to ask the
panelists and I think we'll start with
Molly and work our way this way
how important is the question of when
life begins to the abortion debate
what's your answer to that and is the is
a coterminous that when life begins
rites begin okay easy questions yes well
actually you're already running out of
time in some sense when the question of
when life begins is not it's not really
that relevant at all everyone knows when
life begins by deafening
human life begins at conception so we're
all in agreement on that if we're all I
think that's a debating tactic I mean
wait maybe I'm wrong about that but I
think it's almost like it's a truism
human life begins at conception the
question is when do human rights begin
what can can you also define before we
get to human rights
when does conception begin that's just
it's it's like a circular question
people love each other what a mommy and
a daddy when a mom and dad were realized
how little I knew about this no no but I
mean is it when went what is the moment
of conception because that actually has
real ramifications for certain types of
contraception is it when an egg gets
fertilized as when it implants in the
uterine wall is it when it has developed
be very simple I don't think there's
really debate on that there are debates
about like one pregnancy begins
some people say pregnancy begins at the
moment of conception some people say
pregnancy it sort of like a change that
has happened in recent decades or people
say pregnancy begins when the fertilized
egg implants in the wall of the uterus
but as far as conception that's just a
you know medical term for when the male
material in the female material okay so
it's fertilization for you okay and and
do rights begin at that point that's
right actually just to say I think this
is really great that we're having this
debate because even though abortion is
not the most contentious topic among
libertarians this question of when and
how rights are how how humans have
rights is very important to so many
issues and so yes I would say human
rights come as a function of being human
and they should they should begin when
you begin and and so I sort of
categorically reject the idea that we
should be coming up with arbitrary lines
at which point other people decide that
you have rights you just get them by
virtue of your existence you should get
them okay so a fertilized egg has the
same rights as anybody on this panel
well do you mean by in terms of like the
right to life yeah well I'm just saying
you know maybe being libertarian means
that you believe an equal equal
protection under the law and that people
should have equal rights and yes the the
right to life is fundamentalist ron
bailey do you agree that the moment of
conception or the start of life is
really a gray area and we're not and
then you know what about rights no I
agree that that everybody in this room
was once a Zico well everybody in this
room everybody out there listening was
once a fertilized egg the question is
when do they have rights when do they
became when do they become people and as
a matter of fact it's pretty well known
that at least 80% of fertilized eggs
never implant they never become creative
pregnancy they never become people and
therefore I find it odd to give rights
to things that don't become people
typically so basically what I would like
to do is that we also have a sliding
scale of rights people get more rights
as they become older over time we don't
allow children to do certain kinds of
things and so I think that that is part
of that continuum is that we can think
about whether persons have rights or not
and when you become a person and I would
argue that at very early stages of our
existences we were not persons how do
you I mean but we also don't say well
children they can't vote they can't try
but they also can't be killed
you know III I understand that but again
as a sliding scale of when you get some
rights so if you want to say the right
there life is fundamental in some sense
it is in some sense but the only four
persons when would you say personhood
begins that if that's where you know
rights begin for you at some stage it
would have to be with a significant
enough brain development to be able to
have some sense of self-awareness which
could eliminate rule and half the people
yeah the other problem with that is I
I'm very much more comfortable with
viability as a standard because that is
at the point where someone else gets
decide to start taking care of the
entity debate the baby the fetus
whatever you would like as opposed to
imposing the the burden on the the woman
who's carrying the fetus to maintain but
and you do agree on some level with
Molly though then that that line of
viability is is either arbitrary errs
always going to be revised based on new
technologies or understandings of
biological process yes I do think it'll
be revised but the critical thing is
whether or not the
the the born child is able to be taken
care of by somebody else
Katherine do you have a clearer sense of
when human life begins and how does that
relate to when rights begin yeah so
obviously first I just want to note for
those who don't know that I am also the
hilarious token pro-choice pregnant lady
on this panel which you know that's I
suspect that we started planning this
many months ago I suppose like this
whole thing is actually somehow just
like a practical joke by Nick on me so
let's assume that as our kind of
starting point no I mean what I actually
think about this question is I don't
know any of the answers probably to any
of the questions that you're going to
ask in the next hour they're really
really hard questions and you know Ron
Bailey is an incredibly smart dude and
he just was like my ability reason
self-awareness he just said like 17
things that all are different places and
molly is a really really smart lady and
she just said like magical rights
happened when sperm equals egg or when
sperm hits egg and yeah you know as a
skeptic of the idea of natural rights
there's sort of a whole sub debate to be
had there but sort of position that I'm
going to take for the purposes of this
debate is I don't know the answers lots
of really really smart people disagree
on the answers this suggests to me that
we should devolve decisions on this to
the lowest possible level and that it is
wildly unlikely that the state will
arrive at the right answers and
Institute those in law in some kind of
way that's morally please so that means
essentially that abortion should be
legal and you pick or not ubiquitous but
widely available yeah I want abortion to
be safe legal universe had you back with
us yes yeah no but no no that I that I
essentially think you know at some point
we just have the sort of biological
distinction of birth which I don't think
necessarily has strong moral weight but
which has very very strong customary
weight and that up to that point it's
essentially an individual decision and
that
it's an individual decision not only on
the part of the woman carrying the fetus
but also on the part of providers that
is that if we are going to have a regime
where the state does not pronounce on
the legality of abortion it we must also
have a regime where the state does not
force people to provide these abortions
because there is this tricky moral
situation where it's tough to give
yourself an abortion would you although
it's getting easier I mean literally no
it I mean this is part of you know world
yoga that Americans know but we're in
the very early stages of gaining any
significant control over our biology and
our absolutely so a 486 morning-after
pills which are not abortifacients but
or at least by most counts but the one
thing that has I think quite
legitimately informed the divorce
abortion debate in the past is the fact
that you you must involve particularly
for later stage abortions a third party
who is also a world actor who deserves
to me here is their own autonomous
choice here's a question for you very
quickly than I want to get Molly's
reaction to what catherine was saying do
you think the legal status of abortion
changes the the incidence the occasion
of the action because you know there
were abortions before it was legal and
after it was legal and whatnot you know
we know
libertarians talk about a lot about drug
use and it seems from a lot of
international comparisons that the legal
regime is not particularly important and
whether or not people choose to use
drugs that are you know legally or
illegally so you know if we got if
abortion was made illegal with the
numbers change radically if it was made
totally legal up until the moment of
birth would that change things I mean I
actually think the prohibition analogy
is a good one and it's one that
libertarians debating abortion in
particular should sort of naturally
weigh more heavily I think then than
other types of people when they think
about this question that we perhaps
better than any other kinds of
ideologues or people of different
political persuasions understand that
prohibition is not the same thing as
eliminating that thing and on the flip
side though I do think law influences
behavior and people have fewer abortions
be
has abortions are illegal so if that is
your only imperative to reduce the
number of abortions period and you don't
you're willing to accept the second the
second level consequences of prohibition
then you you may still understand it
would be pro-life I think these are two
completely separate questions I mean
abortion has been around ever since
women figured out that they could do
abort have abortions they've been doing
abortions thousands of years of history
on this that has it's a separate
question of whether we think as
libertarians there's a place for the law
to talk about whether all humans have
equal protection under the law or
whether we're going to prescribe that
some do and some don't but it is an
important step I think yes so how do you
feel about you know what Katherine or
what Ron were sketching out of you know
because we can't know for sure or you
know then birth is the is the dividing
line or viability which has changed even
in the past you know in the years since
Roe vs. Wade
viability has moved backwards you're
closer to the moment of conception there
been tremendous there's been tremendous
progress in terms of viability children
that were born you know ten weeks
premature a few years ago wouldn't make
it now it's been pushed back quite a bit
but I just worry about the way we talk
about these issues because when we're
what we're talking about is that someone
has worth only if they have a certain
utility or someone has worth only if
they have a certain brain function I
think that can take us to a very
dangerous place and has throughout
history when you decide that certain
people have Worth and certain people
don't or you define sort of arbitrarily
well those are people those aren't
people we can do whatever we want with
those people we can't do it with those
very dark places we just placed on the
devil's advocate but we're always doing
that right because we don't mourn the
spontaneous abortions as fertilized eggs
well you you mourn the death of your
grandpa who's 92 in a very different way
than you do if he'd been shot through
the heart
that's that doesn't mean that those
people have different moral worth it
just means that you know some things are
natural some things aren't I mean yes
naturally some some people miscarry this
happens very common for a lot of women
it's different than like going in and
like tearing something apart limb by
limb I mean that's just it's very
different but I wonder wait what do you
mean when you say we write like this is
that you know what you
we Kemosabe this is this is my concern
here is you know there is certainly a
completely legitimate and rich debate
among philosophers and you know at bars
and the cultural side of this debate
which i think is very related to another
phenomenon that libertarians are are
keen on or should be keen on which is
the notion of the expanding circle right
that we are you know one of the great
triumphs of libertarianism you know writ
large across history is that we treat
more and more people like people like we
treat ourselves or like wheat right that
we treat more and more people like one
of us rather than others right and you
know that that this this argument goes
all kinds of places including the
abolition of slavery and abuse of force
I'm saying we feel differently about the
use of force but to end someone's life
well then we do a phrase we feel derive
well the other problem is you're saying
there is someone and that's the that's
what I think is at dispute you really
because I would argue because it's a
fertilized egg that is not necessarily
somewhat you have to show that to me and
I don't know what kind of evidence you
would be able to come up with that would
in fact being able to persuade me and
I'm not sure what evidence I could
provide you that would get you on my
side of the debate either I don't know
the answer to that kind of question so
you're on can I ask a question because
one of the things that I wanted to move
into is what's the role of science or
religion or a philosophy in deciding
these because at a certain level we can
talk about the biology of things and you
know what's going on but then it's it's
not fully clear that science or religion
or philosophy or ethics will actually
give us the moral answers that we want
so if you can't say here's evidence that
shows us as a person and you can't be
you know you can't be persuaded
what are you used to go on what I mean
where are you coming up with you do the
best you can with the information that
you have provided to yourself I mean you
you look at all the questions that are
related to personhood what happens to
80% of the fertilized eggs that has some
relevance I think it has some relevance
to it or those who are not persons or
you think about a I thought here's the
thought experiment you you have a
three-year-old boy and
and ten seven day old embryos and in a
laboratory that's catching on fire you
can only save what which one do you say
the three-year-old or the ten seven
seven day old embryos I wanted it take
us to get to lifeboat exactly my point
is that you you have everybody has
different day to into it intuitions
about this particular issue I think and
and you try to do the best you can you
struggle with it and you also try to
think about what it is that you're
trying to impose on women as well you're
trying to think well do you want to
force women to have children that they
don't want and so it's a it's a whole
panoply of things that comes to what you
can what you yourself can do in the in
the honesty of your own heart but just
very quickly to pick up on that because
then we'll go on to a couple other
points one of the things that's
interesting is that even a lot of very
staunch opponents of abortion will say
okay you know no abortions except in the
case of the light to preserve the life
of the mother which is a kind of
long-standing medical precept that if
you can save one life that's better than
losing two and we could argue that but
then the loss of say and in the case of
rape and incest Mississippi and
researching this interestingly the only
cause before Roe versus Wade that
Mississippi allowed abortion for was
incest not rate but incest and it's kind
of like if you're the Mississippi
tourist board you know you would
probably would want to rethink that and
come up with more you know if you know
why would incest be the only thing that
would legitimate it but can we all agree
on some level that yeah that's it cut
but but you know that these carving out
exceptions for things like rape and
incest possibly even the life of the
mother you know seemed kind of strange
because it's like you know the argument
against rape is that well a woman didn't
consent to become pregnant or have this
child but then it's like okay so to you
know to make it alright we're gonna kill
the kid I actually don't think it's
weird I mean I think that's how we make
all of our moral decisions I mean
there's there's everybody has these
incredibly complex and individualized
preferences and when you talk to you
know individual women about why they
have abortion
everyone has a different reason everyone
has a different you know series of
things that they valued in a different
order and and I guess I think the weird
part is why have we empowered state
legislatures or courts to say these
three things are good reasons these 37
things are bad reasons it doesn't strike
me as weird that we would have a long
list of reasons and want to accept
something perfectly by the way are they
according to survey data the top two
reasons that women cite for getting an
abortion one is that they want twenty
six percent said they want a postponed
child birth and twenty-one percent say
it's because they don't have the money
or that means to take care of the child
Ron you were gonna well that one is
historically one of the fascinating
things is abortion in the United States
was not illegal until the 1830s at all
every state it was legal and there was
no prohibition whatsoever against it and
why didn't we get the prohibitions it
wasn't the Catholic Church or anything
like that it was the American Medical
Association it was a bunch of you of
basically white Protestant guys who
wanted to take away midwifery and take
over the obstetrics on their hand and
they were also very concerned and you
can go back and reread the history of
all this bathing in a very concern
because the Irish Catholics were having
too many babies and the white Protestant
women weren't therefore we were going to
force the white pros and women to have
babies and by outlawing abortion and
that's just historically the fact and by
by essentially the eighteen the late
1860's it was illegal in every state
that gets into the whole crazy
progressive and eugenics past of their
general abortion movement but i just
want to say one thing that really
concerns me about the way we're talking
about that i'm sorry i had to take it
into the progress what this was this was
the American Medical Association for me
at the looking back into a hundred years
ago and what not there was a lot of
eugenics motivation for abortion and our
general culture there whatever eugenics
started to factor into discussions a
reproduction troll of right but what I'm
concerned about is how we're talking
about an entire class of people and
deciding that they're not people and
we're sort of making this arbitrary
saying oh well why should why should we
say that women can or can't do this well
we're forgetting to talk about the
people that are involved the the human
beings that are that are killed because
we think that we should
have any say in how and what women are
doing it's not just a function they're
competing rights in play and I think
that we it's important to talk about all
the parties involved when we are talking
about ending human life in the world and
you know on that if people could quickly
comment on what's the role of the of the
father in this because there's the
rights of the mother competing rights
the rights of the mother the rights of
the fetus or child and then there's the
father do they have any role to play Ron
you seem to be sneaking out the most
feminist position self-consciously
feminist position so let's service him I
actually think that they probably have
no role and deciding that I would hope
that couples who come to this decision
will talk about it but ultimately it is
really going to have to be the longest
decision because it is hard body and
what is happening to her is happening to
her I mean there's a great deal of your
logic on that part too though when you
talk about if this child does somehow
escape the birth canal then we have the
fathers being completely responsible for
them but they have no say and whether
they make it out of the birth canal but
they we do punish them if they procure
an abortion for their for the woman that
they impregnated particularly against
her well I mean there's just there's a
lot of your logic in the in the legal
structure here and again I agree with
you I would just take the position that
yes there is a lot of a logic and the
legal structure all the more reason to
strip down the legal structure to remove
this from the business of the law and
make it the business of individuals and
I think you're right to say that you
know many many people hopefully I think
most people and certainly more and more
people as history progresses will
consider the fetus slash baby to be a
person worthy of consideration to be a
moral entity in this calculation but we
also for instance agree that it is a
morally permissible decision to shoot
someone in self-defense if they're
attacking you we also agree that there
there's that the right to life is not
one that somehow everyone is very mushy
on in this abortion debate and then like
hardline on in every other circumstance
it's just not true we have gray areas
everywhere and the places where we can
let people including fathers make their
own world
about this and not draw a bright line
sorbets rarely buy the state I think is
the libertarian position and
coincidentally the right position what
what do you guys make of the fact I mean
there's some paradox old paradoxical
results in the survey data as I was
saying the the overall numbers people
who say that it should be lis abortion
should be legal under some circumstances
all circumstances under no circumstances
has it really changed that much but you
know since the early 70s but the number
of people who call themselves pro-life
has actually increased and the number of
state restrictions that have been placed
on abortion procedures has increased
dramatically especially over the past 10
years but especially in the last two
could it be possible that people are
still generally comfortable with the
idea of abortion under some
circumstances particularly in the first
trimester even as they're recognizing
more and more rights or potential
personhood for the fetus I think those
survey results are actually encouraging
from the perspective of potentially more
libertarian outlook by the general
population I mean what you're describing
is people are generally more comfortable
with the idea of abortion being legal
even as they are made maybe are
simultaneously less comfortable with
actually doing you're actually having
abortions employed we're not even true
necessarily by the data though people
say yeah they actually are both in raw
numbers and in rates but even around to
the late eighties certainly
demonstrating preferences are relevant
here like no doubt about that but just
to the extent that people are saying
they're pro-life and also saying you
know the sort of Venn diagram of people
who are saying they're pro-life and are
saying abortion should be legal are
perhaps the people who are who are wary
of these increasing state restrictions
because I a quick question as well I'm
just curious what do you think of the
moral status of embryos that are
produced for in vitro fertilization that
are actually in lab dishes that is I
mean I don't I don't know what you mean
exactly but are they persons yes I think
that well let me ask you I know what I
was gonna say I wonder I don't think
it's good though is to have this
discussion with too much of an eye
toward public opinion meaning as
libertarians I think that we should we
should advocate things or oppose things
on principle and not based on whether
it's tough or not and a lot of things
that we advocate that used to be deeply
unpopular now growing in popularity in
part because of our principle approach
to it anything from I think that's a
very good point but it's also
interesting just to see how it seems
like there are broad cultural shifts
because you know where abortion became
possible it became imaginable
not because of Roe versus Wade Roe vs.
Wade is actually kind of an emanation of
that based on a variety of cultural
sense so it's always in agree principles
matter but it's always interesting to
look in a larger context let me ask you
since you're right forgave religion org
is there a role for religion in setting
abortion policy or how does that
influence in the same way I'd asked Ron
about science because it seems to me
science is not particularly helpful or
it's not determinative in this how does
religion kind of factor into your
thoughts about what's good public policy
well there's always a role for religion
in the same way there's a role for any
any belief system and that a vibrant
public square' should hear from from all
sorts of perspectives from the
libertarian perspective I don't really
think it plays to much of a role except
there was something that Katherine
picked up on when she referred to
natural lights natural rights is kind of
magical and if there is a truth that
when you look at the history of like of
our country our founding fathers
definitely thought of natural rights
being endowed by creators if you if you
reject a belief in God seems like
sometimes there's also a rejection of
natural rights that goes along with that
so I think that it's interesting but
it's not like a direct
there's no direct role necessarily and
it's clear we define natural rights
differently than the founding fathers
did do we you know I you know I think
there's large percentages of the
population yeah
let's quick thing on the on the religion
thing one of the one of the and I think
religion obviously has a legitimate
place in the debate the problem is is
that you know if God is telling you that
a fertilized egg is a human being why
would you ever pay any attention to ron
bailey and it's that kind of precludes
an argument in a certain sense because
you already have a reason to think that
way provided transcendentally and the
debate is over there is no it's probably
worth noting too that historically
speaking people who are religious
particularly of the judeo-christian
variety tend to have a more expansive
view of human rights as compared to say
like communist countries that officially
rejected religion and have rejected all
sorts of human rights that go along with
it so if there's a danger there i think
the danger for a libertarian is that a
world that's particularly hostile to
religion is a world that tends not to
have a very high view of civil liberties
in general i'm not sure that's actually
the right account of history though that
is you're absolutely right that
religious thinkers and religious people
were were and are crucial in the sort of
expanding circle right this notion of a
bright scent of you know other
individuals is being worthy of respect
and equal treatment but i think that the
recent history of that is just as much a
secular phenomenon as it is a religious
phenomenon and I am I'm not convinced
that sort of the rise of secularism
equals the decline of natural rights at
this point I do think that there have
been moments in human history when
secularism and lack of respect for human
rights have been intertwined but I don't
I don't believe that that is a necessary
let's go into a final kind of serious
question of them we'll open it up for
the audience what's the role of the
state then in either prohibiting or
regulating abortion very quickly Molly
what would you say well I just want to
say I think this is actually why a lot
of libertarians get along and don't
disagree too much we but all of the
debates that are about abortion right
now are about whether the state should
be funding abortion funding embryonic
stem cell research forcing employers to
pay for abortifacients and whatnot it
doesn't matter how much our views differ
we probably agree up to a large
perspective on that so when you look at
the actual debates about the government
there's a lot of agreement in
libertarian circles I do think there is
I think that even the most strenuous
pro-life advocate would say that most of
what needs to be accomplished in terms
of creating a culture that respects life
happens outside of the state should the
state have laws that give equal
protection to all humans absolutely
so I mean you would be comfortable with
ending abortion on demand essentially I
mean the policy wo you know Ron what
about you know what's your sense of
what's the state's role in this and if
abortion I mean you believe abortion
should be legal one of the things that
came out of the Gosnell trial in
Philadelphia was you know there was a
regulatory regime in place that really
was obviously totally asleep in any
number of ways but you know should the
state be placing limits on abortion and
then how should it be read I would like
to associate myself with Katherine mango
Ward's comments no yeah I mean
essentially to the ascent you need a
regulatory regime to ensure safety and
that kind of thing that's fine I'm not
going to strenuously worry about that
but essentially there should be no role
in the state just making decisions with
regard to this procedure sorry
Ron's use of the word safety sent
Molly's eyebrows disappearing into her
hairline so if anyone wants to sort of
poke safety for a woman who is a person
no no I mean I I basically think that
the state has has shown itself time and
time again to be spectacularly inept at
enforcing prohibitions of things that
people want to do that it has been
spectacularly inept in drawing
regulatory bright lines that are not
also the don't don't also produce
unintended consequences of epic
proportions and that if we think that
for instance markets are so complicated
and so subtle that right you know
attempts by the state to regulate them
will invariably fail I I don't see why
sort of far more important moral
question would somehow be something that
the state would be equipped to handle
and then just the final question before
we go to the audience does the do your
positions on abortion have any
implications for your positions on
contraception are other forms of kind of
reproductive technologies and I guess
Molly you would say if in vitro eggs are
have full personhood you know does that
change the you know very more procedures
than just what we're talking about in
terms of abortion I'm not quite sure
what you're getting at with that
although I do wish people would learn a
lot more about contraception how it how
it accomplishes what it's intended to
accomplish and what happens if the
initial efforts to contracept fail
whether you're well you know some
contraception seem to be you know they
prevent fertilizations others or
abortifacients about your time sometimes
we call the board a patient's
contraceptives which is great confusing
i what i what i do think is important
those that people also think about IVF
and all sorts of assisted reproductive
technologies and what they're doing you
know there's sort of movements to kind
of create embryos for harvesting and
whatnot and this again is just it's kind
of very scary territory to go into and i
wish people would really think about
what the technology means the the lives
they're creating and how they're
treating those i have thought about that
considerably i would like to think but
and one of the things i was very puzzled
by when i was thinking about this debate
i went looked back at a statement that
former Pope Benedict said basically
about IVF where he said you know if you
if you've created embryos that and in
fact you have genetic defects that
perhaps tay-sachs or something like that
they should nevertheless be implanted
they are people and I find that to be
horrific as a matter of fact basically
you're creating lives that will not be
conscious the tay-sachs baby is a
horrible horrible painful position to be
in
i those are the kinds of logical
consequences that come from feeding
every fertilized egg as a person they
simply or not and you end up in all
kinds of cul-de-sacs where you will
cause much more harm than you would do
good i would think i just want to end
also on the warm fuzzy Molly Hemingway
note of commonality of agreement here I
mean I
I think it is it is exactly right to say
that despite the very widely varying
positions we all come to a lot of the
same places on actual policy
prescriptions and I think contraception
is a great example of that and that you
know contraception a okay in my book but
forcing forcing any entity and not just
people with religious objections but you
know a corporation with their eye on the
bottom line or you know whatever it
might be you know forcing people to pay
for contraception forcing doctors or
medical providers to prescribe it to
perform abortions all of those things
are just as objectionable from the
overweening state power perspective as
as any other right well thank let's have
a hand for Molly Hemingway Ron Bailey
and Katherine manga Ward and let's have
some questions from the audience who who
has a question there's Phil Harvey yes
obviously somebody knows so okay my name
is Phil Harvey I'm a dkt international a
family planning organization I'm curious
about the what we once called a decent
respect for the opinions of mankind it
seems to be a fact that modern
democracies generally liberalize
abortion laws that is they become
relatively permissive assuming putting
aside the the Communists and other
authoritarian regimes assuming that
modern democracies are reasonably
expressive of the desires and principles
of their people does this not suggest
particularly to you Molly that human
beings persons whatever have a tendency
to find the availability of abortion at
least in the early trimesters to be less
objectionable at all then
the horrors that attend illegal abortion
it's kind of interesting to think about
the horrors that attend the illegal
abortion right after this Kermit Gosnell
trial which took place after decades of
legal abortion and a regime that
completely supports that and yet still
we have you know feline infested flea
riddled clinics with women being killed
and a guy who was just convicted of
three charges of first-degree
manslaughter which suggests that maybe
there's something about the abortion
culture that also leads to a general
dehumanizing of of patients and whatnot
but I don't really think the fact that
people are generally supportive of
something in a certain point in time
really means that much I mean we have in
very recent history had some pretty
horrific examples of people being
generally supportive of absolutely
horrible treatment of their fellow man
deciding that entire classes of people
do not have the right to life or Liberty
liberty or their property it happens all
the time and I think that it is
incumbent upon people who do respect
life that we educate people have strong
social institutions that encourage
people not to destroy life or initiate
force against their fellow man that
works not just in terms of abortion but
all the ways that we initiate force
against people when we don't have the
right to run were you about so I just
wanted to object the I this notion that
there's a whole regime that supported
guys no I do want to point out that he
is in fact in jail for murder so I don't
think there's many decades of doing what
I suggest you that we had a terrible
regulatory regime well I mean but it is
interesting that Gosnell is exactly the
type of person who should not exist in a
legalized but we would exist in an
illegal world right that's my point okay
very good
other questions yes I'm a Patrick melody
I'm not particularly affiliated with
anyone at this point but I do have a
reason t-shirt shirt so yeah anyway
thanks for saying that Nick um so Ron I
have a question for you seem pretty
convinced that as I got is not in fact a
person though it I suppose is human
you've also alluded that you've said
it's you know
what's a person who's a person are you
conscious or you know you've said that
these things are of course extremely
difficult you know from both a
scientific point also I guess a moral
non scientific point of view it's very
hard to determine this anyway so my
question is is there any kind of is
there in principle any proposition or
something that would look like a
proposition that you can think of that
if we could prove it to you or if we
could come if we could show very
compelling evidence that was very likely
true is there something that would
change your mind though that would would
there be is that in principle possible
what would that look like if I need me I
have been writing about stem cells and
abortion and so forth for twenty years
I've been looking for that principle
that entire time I've read very I think
fairly widely in the field and I cannot
find out what that would be I in
principle yes there should be something
that could persuade me one way or the
other but it would be hard
I just haven't encountered an argument
in favor of that at this point if you
happen to have one let's have a drink
sometime and discuss it but I I just I
don't see it out there that's just an
empirical matter and that's I guess
where I have to come down on that one
another way to think about it though and
I is I like to we can also lose our
humanity over time as adults and one of
the problems of course is you could you
could be brain dead and we don't treat
people who former people on those who
have to refer to them as if their brain
did we can harvest their organs they
don't have brains anymore and to that
extent that kind of thinking might also
inform a little bit about what we should
think about entities that don't have
brains in the first place which would be
zygotes and whether they deserve the
same source of rights as people who do
have working brains Ron could you very
briefly also just talk about the
creation of the concept of brain death
and where does you know how recent is
that as I well as it it's incredibly
recent is people probably may or may not
remember the first
heart transplants actually took place in
South Africa in the early 1960s and they
were using the hearts from people who
were in car accidents and brain dead
basically kept on life-support and this
was incredibly controversial at the time
and you could read newspaper headlines
that they were murdering people to steal
their organs and that kind of thing and
so a committee met at Harvard in the
late 1960s to come up with a definition
if they could which basically hold brain
death basically that you need to be on
life-support entirely in order to be
considered dead and so but until that
point death for most human beings was
the Association of a heartbeat but now
we had a different opinion because we
have different ways of thinking about
what constitutes human identity and a
large part of that has to do with having
a working brain other questions yeah hi
i'm david barnes with e 21 economic
policies we're trying for a century my
questions for katherine you started off
before getting sidetracked talking about
the expanding circle of liberty and i
want to know why you think that fetus is
still in the womb aren't maybe the next
stop in that expanding circle i think
they might be but i think that the whole
the whole kind of force of and it's not
the expanding circle of liberty the sort
of the term originates with a more
general concept i think of an expanding
moral circle or a circle of bus'ness
rather than other neces nick alluded to
I am quite open to the fact that fetuses
and you know cows are currently kind of
the leading contenders for the next
entity to be welcomed into the circle
but those are those are first and
foremost cultural decisions they are
decisions that should be made on the
individual level in the same way that I
think even the vegetarians among us many
vegetarians among us might not think
that it's appropriate to sort of
immediately confer the rights of humans
on to cows if we decide that we can't
treat them any old way we want at the
same time I think there is lots of gray
area there's lots of more
gray area as well as legal gray area
between fetuses might be people - and
fetuses deserve all of the protections
under the law of people right now so I
am open to the question open to the
notion that in the future that we will
actually look back and say we are
thoroughly embarrassed at ourselves for
our treatment of fetuses I I do not yet
think we are there and I don't think
that the immediate kind of treatment of
fetuses as full people is appropriate at
this point and their computing rights I
mean in many there is this sort of huge
body of philosophical work on on the
sort of problem of and actually at
Kennedy just referred me to a great
essay which posits among other things
what if you woke up one morning and
found that a incredibly talented
violinist had been grafted onto one of
your kidneys and you were the only match
that could keep him alive and that you
either had to sort of stay in bed with
him for nine months or nine years and
nine days or nine minutes and what are
our moral intuitions about that scenario
and how is it analogous to pregnancy so
as someone who is currently urgently
resentful of like the sharing of my
kidneys right now I you know I I
actually I do see some sort of some
space in this debate for the competing
claims point I'm just gonna say who says
libertarian thought is not always
practical yeah I mean I every any
morning you could wake up with this
violinist where would you be this
actually wasn't a libertarian at all
it's just a philosophy it is one thing
thank ya I'm betting it was a violinist
it's it's something I was thinking as
someone had said to me the other day
that there are no children in Iran
novels and it is definitely a truth you
know a lot of people would say there are
no adults but it is a real nerds would
say actually there are like two of them
right at the end of Atlas right yeah so
there yes okay well um but it yes it
gets to the problem that we have in
general with libertarianism is which is
that it is like the most perfect system
in the world until children are involved
so I do think these are very important
debates for us to be having if everybody
were an adult
these debates would be so much easier
when people are reliant on us these
debates are much more difficult whether
they are grafted onto our kidney or
otherwise I have to say I I this this
sort of libertarianism is perfect and
ideal and utopian except for this thing
that it fails to deal with I have to
think I think those arguments are rarely
true and I think you know you've
probably been in debates about other
issues on which you are you know sort of
taking the libertarian position people
say oh yes that's all very well and good
but you know it's not practical or
libertarianism doesn't have room for
these practical considerations and you
often would say no no it does let me
explain it to you
I actually think the same is true of
children and and that that argument is
just sort of a an unfair I think just in
general in terms of how we always talk
about individual rights children bring
up a whole host of obligations which are
not as friendly to the general no that's
interesting and I also think that it's
worth thinking about generational
changes in this a lot of people in the
modern libertarian movement a lot of men
got into it because of the military
draft and a lot of women got into it
about abortion rights or reproductive
choice and you know that's 40 45 years
ago and we've dealt with a lot of these
issues in ways that what it means to be
a libertarian let's talk about things
now is very different because I know a
lot of the people when I started at
Reason 20 years ago a lot of the people
who were there had not had children and
all of my colleagues basically with the
exception of Ron you know have children
so it this idea that libertarianism is
somehow particularly you know
Impa incapable of dealing with children
I think might have been true certainly
it seems to have been true in ID rands
world not so true anymore also weirdly
except for you all of them have girl
children I have optimist I have often
describe myself as a double genetic
loser and
mahat I have that beats my kids or
quintuple or I don't know they have
wrinkled peas I'm sure for the Mendel
fans out there we will end this good
conversation I think I've learned a lot
and I hope other people found it
interesting and stimulating and
provocative to really kind of test the
boundaries are kind of kicked the tires
on a topic which is of great importance
and also one that it's not perhaps as
clear you know as other kinds of
concerns and topics for libertarian so
again I want to thank Molly Hemingway of
ricochet and get religion org for
participating along with Rob Bailey
recent science correspondent and
Katherine mango Ward a reasons a
managing editor and a about to become a
mother of two over the course of the
next few months so and thank you all for
coming